france bat irlande dit phaneuf troisième
victoire consécutive du quinze de france
dans le tournoi des cinq nations
la fuite d'une conduite d'une conduite
de gaz c'est bien l'origine des
tragiques d'explosion du 16e
arrondissement prise d'otages à chypre
un ancien ministre égyptien tuer les
terroristes seraient des palestiniens
quels risques nous font courir les
supertankers une équipe d'antenne 2 à
bord du plus gros pétroliers du monde
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
l'été les téléspectateurs d'antenne 2
n'ont pas été volés cet après midi le
spectacle offert au parc des princes à
paris et ensuite vers larmes ce park de
cardiff valait le coup d'autant plus que
finalement dans le tournoi des cinq
nations tout se jouera je crois pas ce
que dira comme prévu par roger couderc
le 18 mars prochain au pays la france en
effet gagné son troisième match dans le
tournoi 78 après l'angleterre après les
casses ce sont les irlandais qui ont été
battus par le quinze tricolore à score
étriqué 10 à 9 qui reflète même assez
mal la physionomie de la partie et
surtout la domination française tout au
long de cette partie fpk grande partie
d'ailleurs par l'état du terrain et
premières images vous montre que le
terrain est glissant des gelées et les
joueurs ne peut pas prendre correctement
leurs assises
gliese ont de la peine à se tenir debout
première mêlée
sega lyon qui va être pénalisé pour
avoir mal introduit la balle mais la
pénalité ne sera pas réussie par words
words qui a été un grand joueur le plus
grand joueur irlandais sur le terrain
elle sera pas réussi
regardez ma gueule octobre qui prend la
bad qui tendent qui t'a pas en
catastrophe voyez les joueurs vous
pouvez vraiment pas souvenir de vous ils
ont eu beaucoup de mérite si 30 joueurs
nous ont offert une partie comme vous
disiez tout à l'heure à ces remarques à
la veille avoir une faute de keane
regardez bien troisième ligne est hors
jeu nettement la vitre le voir et siffle
on croit supériorité pas du tout c'est
d'une mêlée avec introduction française
mais regardez bien ce qui va se passer
sur sept mais vous allez voir le grand
homme du match l'action galion poussée
française forte basse terre mastaba de
l'aga lyon qui s'infiltrent avec des
gens formidables entre 3 et 9 et sidéré
et qui m'a reconnaissent un manoir au
ralenti parce qu'il en vaut la peine
vraiment remarquable alors ils marquent
un essai par match
il a marqué un essai par match jusqu'à
présent 23 ans est une nation
remarquable au ralenti un avenir encore
plus aux couleurs basse et ramasse la
balle donne à gaillon regardez il ya
trois irlandais quatre bientôt ils
passent tout le monde et va marquer
seule la france mène 4-0 souvient partie
des vingt minutes on joue mais les
hollandais s'accroche très beau départ
moloney mcg mclaughlin gipson le
merveilleux gibson qui passe intérieure
hop là une caresse il faut dire un peu
trop appuyé vaut une pénalité aux
guirlandes et world encore lui la tente
c'est là entre les murs entre les
mimosas regardez c'est joli ils nous
avaient posé par des admirateurs il va
taper il tape et laval passe entre les
mimosas 4 à 3 pour la france la france
mènera toujours d'un point mais ne le
quittera pas à ce point et ses
principales
vous avez vu aguirre était plaqué sans
ballon et l'arbitré accorde une pénalité
aux points de chute du ballon et à gears
ne va pas manquer cette occasion vous
pensez 7 à 3 pour la france
il est content grands joueurs grande
partie aujourd'hui car les mêlées
ouvertes et mon jeu comme l'air comme on
peut est ce une nouvelle pénalité c'est
parce que c'est panique à se relever que
c'est lui qui était hors jeu là c'est
pas con qui se relèvent ses palmiers qui
était hors-jeu et world réussit une
pénalité 7 assists pour la france
toujours ce fameux petit point mais à
gears finalement la 45e minute
on joue les arrêts de jeu réussit une
pénalité à son tour 10 pour la france 6
pour l'irlande qui marquera par ward à
cinq minutes de la mi-temps une pénalité
10 à 9
et là regardez la france a manqué
beaucoup d'occasions rives rives viviès
bertrade en plein trou le croit travers
ses 22 navires au milieu de quatre
écoutes de 80 des finalement est plaqué
une rue sera pas marquée eu d'autres
essai manqué de très peu
d'après moi celui de cholet était bon
mais ne pas accorder pas l'arbitré n'en
parlons plus et finalement le restera là
anizan un pavé de très belles actions
oui un match qui était quand même
difficile et une lutte indécise jusqu'au
bout alors le 18 mars à cardiff c'est la
grande finale le gall
et oui certains arrivent en finale en
tout cas pour la france c'est fini on a
gagné trois matchs maintenant joue le
grand chelem
les gallois eux sont plus
séquence mais parce qu'il joue les
grands rôles mais oui ils ont gagné
d'accord mais le 4 mars il rencontre
guirlandes boules qui prenait 2 voit il
la rencontre
a dublin le fighting spirit là va jouer
à bloc et les gallois ne sont pas du
tout certain de gagner ce match il le
gagne eh bien je crois le grand chelem a
hérité des immenses mais je tiendrai
rendre hommage aujourd'hui aux irlandais
qui ont quand même c'est une équipe un
peu vieilli mais la crème des ressources
et encourage admirable joue ainsi rangée
on vous retrouve donc pour le prochain
match de l'équipe de france au tournoi
des cinq nations
ce sera la veille du deuxième tour des
élections législatives
cinq morts et une soixantaine de blessés
peut-être encore des disparus trois
immeubles pratiquement détruit toute une
partie du 16e arrondissement est encore
isolées ce soir du reste de paris est
depuis hier soir tout le monde se pose
la même et seule question comment cela
at il pu se passer
après une première enquête le gaz de
france a donné il ya quelques minutes
des précisions pour l'administration du
gaz de france une fuite sur une
canalisation de 70 cm de diamètre s'est
produite sur la section de la rue
raynouard et de l'avenue de lamballe
cette canalisation et est en acier est
intéressante pour le gaz de france
l'hypothèse la plus vraisemblable serait
que la fuite est le résultat d'un
glissement de terrain on en saura plus
dans les jours prochains
après l'examen scientifique de cette
conduite de gaz loin de cette enquête
les habitants du quartier notamment ceux
des immeubles les plus proches du
sinistre ont repris lentement leur
activité pour beaucoup d'entre eux il
faut trouver un logement
en attendant d'être fixé définitivement
certains immeubles ébranlée par la
violence des explosions même s'ils
apparaissent presque intact devront être
abattus quant aux immeubles directement
ravagée par le sinistre
il faudra totalement les reconstruit
depuis hier soir donc la mairie du
xvième arrondissement a accueilli des
réfugiés
il fallait les réconforter leur faire
passer la nuit dans des conditions les
moins mauvaises possibles
pendant que les derniers blessés étaient
dirigés dans les hôpitaux parisiens
on s'occupait à la mairie du 16ème de
recevoir les sinistrés en effet plus de
mille personnes ont été évacuées hier
soir du secteur dangereux et il a fallu
en héberger environ 200 qui n'avait pu
trouver de place ni chez des amis ni
chez des parents les sans abri ont donc
été dirigé sur des hôtels parisiens
mais après le fracas et l'époux ventes
de l'après midi on était un peu
désemparé et souvent sans nouvelles de
proches et peut-être comme le quartier
bouclé il était allé chez un ami raphaël
chaume ils dépendants mais c'est
peut-être aller chez un autre a touché
et qu'elle n'a pas en danger
sur place alors que les pompiers
finissent et seulement d'éteindre les
dernières torchère des personnes
relogées
essayez déjà d'approcher leur
appartement les pompiers sont en train
de tout arrosé ses confrères
peter est votre maison est détruite vous
ne savez pas mais je ne sais pas je
voudrais le savoir il s'est pas là au
moment d'acheter du lait la maison le 28
brûlé ce matin ils sont un peu plus
nombreux à revenir certains autorisent
est entré quelques instants dans leur
appartement en repartent avec quelques
objets que le feu à épargner tous ne
peuvent pas pénétrer dans le périmètre
sinistrés car il ya des risques
d'éboulement corniche en suspens
persiennes pendante et cetera j'ai même
pas de mouchoir
il va maintenant falloir parler des
responsabilités des indemnisations qui
paiera les assurances couvriront tels
les dégâts multiples car outre les vies
humaines des dizaines de voitures sont
écrasées et quatre immeubles ne pourront
être réoccupée avant un an
en effet après tout les catastrophes et
quels que soient leur cause il est
toujours une question que l'on se pose
surtout lorsque l'on songe aux victimes
qui va aller miser tous cas il ya les
assurances bien sûr mais et ont assuré
lorsque un simple passant se passe dans
la rue et qu'il ait tué recevant un
morceau d'une maison qui vient
d'exploser
c'est tout ça vous êtes avec nous ce
soir vous représentez le centre
d'information des assurances en jeu
quoique ce soit il ya trois problèmes
qui se posent il ya celui des habitants
des immeubles dont qui sont sinistrés
totalement il ya le problème des badauds
qui regardaient qui ont été ou blessées
ou tuées pendant les explosions qui ont
suivi il ya celui des conducteurs et des
passagers des voitures qui passaient qui
ont été également blessées par la chute
de gravats il ya plusieurs points à
considérer tout d'abord les dégâts
matériels ils sont bien sûr couverts par
la garantie incendie qui généralement
compris dans les contrats multirisques
habitation hélas aucune difficulté neuf
personnes sur dix possèdent cette
garantie en ce qui concerne les blessés
s'il ya un responsable soit par exemple
en occupant ou éventuellement les casses
de france et si possible
c'est ce responsable qui bien sûr aller
ni sera les victimes ou bien sûr son
assureur oui je joue également
l'assurance individuelle ou l'assurance
vie dont les personnes qui possèdent une
assurance individuelle accident bien sûr
et qui ont été blessés lors de ces
explosions seront bien sûr à des mises
et pour les tuer c'est l'assurance du
qui joue mais lors les partis vers une
enquête qui va certainement durer assez
longtemps
est ce que les assurances vont attendre
le résultat de cette enquête de longue
durée 6 mois non tout est deux ans avec
expertise contre-expertise les contres
contre expertise avant de payer les
dégâts il est bien évident dans un les
explosions aussi importante il faut
d'abord que les experts établissent tous
les tous les dégâts et c'est seulement
après les rapports des experts quand
sera qui est responsable et que les ads
france en fait oui alors genre tout ça
en ce qui concerne le véhicule à présent
il ya évidemment la garantie incendie
explosion mais l'horloge crois que c'est
particulier parce que les assurances ne
remboursent que les véhicules qui ont
été touchés directement par le feu c'est
ça c'est exact pour les pour les
voitures qui ont été endommagées par
l'explosion qui ont été brûlées pas
difficulté c'est la garantie incendie
explosion qui jouera lui il n'y a aucune
voiture qu'elle était touchée
directement par le feu à la france qui
concerne les voitures qui ont été
endommagés par des gravats par exemple
seule une assurance dommages et
accidents
cette assurance qu'on appelle d'ailleurs
tout risque joue pour ce genre
d'accident autrement pour les autres
vous ne payez aux dégâts de vivre
exactement c'est ce qu'ils ont fait ce
qu'ils sont assurés en brie glace
pourront être analysés pour les pour les
classes
alors il est encore trop tôt évidemment
pour sur une estimation d anonymisation
vous avez une idée non aucune aucune
idée pour l'instant c'est lui moi vite
alors que plus est est important plus
seulement des du temps et c'est exact il
faut que tous les experts établissent
leur rapport et que c'est à partir de ce
moment là qu'on croit savoir quel
montant exact des dégâts
alors est ce que est ce que les
assurances ne vont pas se retourner si
la responsabilité de gaz de france est
établie contre gaz de france rentre
l'assurance us
le jugement est établi que c'est les gaz
de france qui est responsable c'est
l'assureur de gaz de france qui aligne
visera tout élective donner conseils les
victimes je suppose doivent se mettre en
rapport le plus rapidement possible avec
leur assurance exactement il ya des
délais ils peuvent bien sûr aussitôt
prévenir leur assureur de l'incident
tout le monde le connaît bien sûr ils
peuvent également s'ils veulent
téléphoner au 0 cdi à vous écrire au cdi
à je rappelle si vous voulez le numéro
de téléphone c'est le 800 24 96 12 et
ils peuvent également venir au cd yassa
dire aux deux chaussées lanta dans le
9ème vient donc le centre d'information
une documentation des assurances 2 rue
de la chaussée d'antin nuit au téléphone
je vous le rappelle le 800 24 96 12
et puis après cette catastrophe donc
dans le 16e arrondissement tout le monde
va craindre désormais la répétition de
semblable accident ainsi dans les
hauts-de-seine les enseignants les
parents d'élèves et aussi les élèves de
la cité scolaire du fort à montrouge ont
demandé aujourd'hui la fermeture de cet
établissement
raison invoquée la vétusté des
canalisations de gaz
la fin de l'année 1977 ne s'était pas
trop mal passé pour l'économie française
l'inflation était en recul et le
commerce extérieur montrent des signes
très nets de rétablissement dans ces
deux domaines l'année 78 commence moins
bien on peut craindre en effet une
légère reprise de la hausse des prix en
raison notamment de la flambée actuelle
des prix des légumes et des volailles
quant au commerce extérieur de la france
les statistiques sont maintenant connus
il a fait une rechute en janvier les
importations l'ont emporté sur les
exportations de plus d'un milliard 800
millions de francs
alors philippe ça si vous êtes avec moi
ce soir comment peut-on expliquer ce
déficit nous avait amené un fort beau
panneau a mené 24 ans beau plein de
cadran un petit peu les tableaux de bord
si vous voulez de l'économie française
laure d'abord un mot sur le commerce
extérieur le fort déficit du mois de
janvier s'expliquent semble-t-il par dh
agroalimentaire faire tout ce qui
concerne l'alimentation ou plus
important que prévu et probablement la
baisse du franc n'est pas étrangère à ce
qui semble être un accident nous étions
sortis du rouge vous avez raison à la
fin de l'année dernière en dix ans nous
avions eu au contraire un excédent des 6
milliards et le déficit total de l'an
passé était de moitié moins important
témoin qui moins important que celui de
1976 met donc en janvier hélas nous
repassons au rouge les prix maintenant
si vous voulez bien
eh bien nous étions
rouge fortement à partir du mois d'avril
avril 3% de hausse au mois d'avril
dernier n'avons cessé effectivement pas
l' indice des prix n'a cessé de
s'améliorer et au mois de décembre la
hausse des prix était de 0,3 pour cent
on n'a pas encore la liste des mois de
jean deux mois de janvier il devrait
être en effet un petit peu plus élevé
que celui ci mais enfin il ya quand même
une amélioration des prix le chômage
maintenant à bien sans entrer dans la
polémique
les chiffres actuellement sur le chômage
il faut bien dire que depuis le mois
d'août où il y avait un million deux
cent quinze mille chômeurs c'est à peu
près un record cela s'est un petit peu
améliorée un million toujours enfin
sommes toujours en rouge
il faut bien dire que le chômage
s'envole on le voit bien à travers les
différents reportages qui sont friands
les circonscriptions électorales que le
chômage reste quand même un des
problèmes du mazeau ascenseurs des
français quelles que soient les
l'activité bien saoulé l'activité on
peut l'apprendre à travers la production
industrielle au début de l'année il y
avait une forte hausse 4,1 pour cent
cette production industrielle au mois
d'avril
et puis cela s'est un petit peu tassée
en janvier ça aussi se meurent passé au
rouge avec 3,1 pour cent de baisse mais
les dernières enquêtes de l'insee de la
banque de france disent que nous
redressons et qu'on mois de janvier nous
sommes ça c'est pour descendre pardon
pour descendre 3% de baisse au mois de
janvier nous avons retrouvé une activité
normale
on espère que pendant le premier
semestre de l'année 1978 et bien la
situation de l'activité sera meilleur
quant à la consommation des ménages elle
a été stimulée par différents facteurs
notamment la hausse des prestations
sociales et on s'attend à ce qu'il
redémarre probablement après les
élections alors qu'est ce que l'on peut
dire sur ces différents cadran qui donne
un tifo et le point sur la situation
économique française à bord ce soit à
peu près les dires des chips sophie prix
que nous attendons avant les élections
deuxièmement il y à une amélioration qui
est certaine c'est les prix le commerce
extérieur quand même sur une tendance un
peu plus longue sauf cet accident du
mois de janvier le chômage très
légèrement mais enfin en conclusion la
situation et est un plat mais le rem
enfin elle reste fragile
superbe peut remercier dans 28 eur c'est
à dire demain soir dimanche à minuit
chacun d'entre nous chaque électeur
connaîtra la liste exacte des candidats
aux élections législatives des 12 et 19
mars prochains
les aspirants candidats devront avoir
fait acte de candidature avant demain
soir minuit et la campagne officielle
pour les élections commencera lundi à
zéro heure
ce dernier week-end de pré campagne
s'annonce eu dans l'ensemble assez calme
les choses très sérieuses commenceront
la semaine prochaine avec pour ouvrir le
feu le premier grand débat organisé
conjointement par antenne 2 et europe
numéro un ce débat aura lieu lundi soir
et il opposera monsieur georges marchais
le secrétaire général du parti
communiste français à monsieur alain
peyrefitte le ministre de la justice
garde des sceaux la discussion
commencera à 20h30 juste après notre
journal lundi soir aujourd'hui de
déclarations à noter celle tout d'abord
de l'amiral antoine sanguinetti qui fait
intervenir si je puis dire l'armée dans
la campagne électorale
pour l'ancien major général de la marine
tout a été mis en place par monsieur
yvon bourges le ministre de la défense
et consciemment ou non par le général
bigeard pour que le président de la
république puisse appliquer l'article 16
de la constitution s'il le juge
nécessaire après les élections
législatives
pour l'amiral sanguinetti l'armée
française a été réorganisé de manière à
la rendre apte au combat à l'intérieur
de nos frontières
le ministère de la défense n'a pas
encore réagi à cette déclaration
mais les propos tenus à metz aujourd'hui
par l'amiral sanguinetti vont
certainement faire quelques vagues dans
les mess des officiers et des
sous-officiers la deuxième déclaration
dont je vous parlais c'est celle qui a
fait à notre mairie trop ce midi
monsieur jean-jacques servan-schreiber
le président du parti radical est revenu
sur plusieurs thèmes qu'il avait déjà
développé durant la campagne mais il a
aussi donné quelques précisions des
précisions notamment sur le salaire
minimum pour jjss le smig à 2400 francs
ce devrait être effectivement l'objectif
du gouvernement français est ce que vous
vous ou moi nous prétendre ayons vivre
avec notre famille pour 2400 francs par
mois ça tout donc dire non au smic à
2400 francs par mois je considère est
une réponse irresponsable
on ne peut pas dire non mais il faut
dire oui dans la vérité alors dire que
au mois d'avril 78 on va d'un seul coup
le gouvernement décrétera qui a le smic
à 2400 francs ce n'est pas raisonnable
parce que ça veut dire que vous
déclenché un processus d'un passion qui
reprend au salarié à qui vous donnez
cet avantage vous le reprenez le pouvoir
d'achat ce qui compte c'est le vrai
pouvoir d'achat
autrement dit je répondrais maintenant
très précisément sur le smic à 2400
francs par mois
je dirais que naturellement ça doit être
un objectif est que nous devons
absolument le confirmer cet objectif
d'abord à l'intérieur de la législature
mais même plus vite
je dirais qu on doit y arriver
normalement et sans inflation est ici
qu'il transformerait en monnaie de singe
en 70 donc l'année prochaine à
l'étranger belfast et nicosie à belfast
quatorze personnes ont été tuées cette
nuit une trentaine d'autres blessées
dans un attentat c'est un restaurant qui
était visé une bombe fait explosion au
moment où 450 personnes environ ont
participé à une soirée dansante
c'est l'attentât le plus meurtrier qui
ait connu l'irlande du nord depuis sept
ans des décombres en flamme de ce
restaurant du sud de belfast où avait
lieu une soirée dansante
les pompiers ont retiré 14 morts dont
plusieurs enfants et au moins 30 blessés
on pense qu'il s'agissait d'une bombe
incendiaire de très forte puissance en
fait un coup de téléphone anonyme à la
manière de l'ira provisoire avait
prévenu la police
mais au même moment la bombe éclatait et
quelques instants plus de 450 personnes
était entouré de flammes c'est le plus
grave incident d'une nouvelle campagne
de terrorisme qui sévit en irlande du
nord
bien que l'attentât n'ait pas encore été
revendiqué la police pense qu'il s'agit
de l'ira provisoire qui a déclenché
depuis quelques semaines une série
d'action terroriste destinée à faire
pression sur l'ombre
la police et l'armée ont lancé une vaste
opération pour identifier les
terroristes les contrôles ont été
multipliés dans les rues et une
vingtaine de personnes connues pour leur
sympathie envers l'ira provisoire ont
été arrêtés à chypre dans la ville de
nicosie une trentaine de personnes ont
été retenu tout au long de cette journée
en otage dans un grand hôtel on ne sait
pas très bien qui sont les terroristes
il pourrait s'agir de palestiniens il
pourrait s'agir aussi dafoe d'asiatiques
pardon ou d'africains membres du front
de libération de l'erythrée
cette prise d'otages a déjà fait en tout
cas une victime s'était les participants
à une réunion de l'organisation de
solidarité des peuples afro asiatique
qui était visé le secrétaire général de
cette organisation assez bas et un
ancien ministre égyptien de
l'information
intime aussi du président anouar el
sadate a été tué presque immédiatement
par les terroristes pour l'instant on ne
sait pas très bien ce que veulent ces
gens ils ont demandé un avion et avec
l'autre vous lisez en ouvrant ce journal
cet avion amenant les terroristes et
leurs otages a décollé peu avant 20
heures vers une direction qui est
actuellement inconnue la pollution nous
en parlons souvent nous vous en parlons
souvent mais il faut le dire nous ne
vous en parlons que lorsque la
catastrophe s'est déjà produite lorsque
le torrey canyon à déverser ces quelques
cent mille tonnes de pétrole en manche
ou lorsque le bol elle s'est plantée sur
les rochers de l'île d'ouessant
et il est vrai que les pétroliers sont
la hantise de tous ceux pour qui la mer
reste l'élément essentiel à la vie de
l'homme et ses pétroliers
ils sont de plus en plus gros quatre
cent mille tonnes 500 mille tonnes et on
parle maintenant de construire des
pétroliers d'un million de tonnes
imaginer les ravages que causerait sur
nos côtes le naufrage de l'un de ses
géants des mers antenne 2 nous allons
nous avons voulu savoir comment la
sécurité étaient respectées abord
comment la lutte contre la pollution
était menée hervé claude durant une
semaine à naviguer à bord du pierre
guillaumat de la compagnie elf aquitaine
vous voulez des précisions et bien
sachez que le pierre guillaumat ce
bateau mesure 430 mètres de long deux
fois la hauteur de la tour montparnasse
et qu'il transporte à chaque voyage ça
sorte 55 mille tonnes de pétrole ce
super tanker c'est le plus gros du monde
ramène chaque fois qu'il revient du
golfe persique 550 mille tonnes de
pétrole
sous ce pont derrière moi un pont si
grands qu'on pourrait y est installé
quatre terrains de football
la course au gigantisme dans le
transport pétrolier a bien sûr
multiplier les risques
alors on a fait appel aux techniques les
plus sophistiquées à cet ordinateur
anticollision par exemple sur son écran
radar à chaque instant apparaissent les
six dangers les plus immédiats
les six bateaux petits ou grands qui se
rapproche le plus par exemple
instantanément l'ordinateur donne pour
chacun de ces bateaux tous les
renseignements possibles distance
vitesse roue de suivi etc
si l'un des bateaux entre dans une zone
jugée dangereuse pour notre pétroliers
l'ordinateur donne une alerte explique
cette alerte est notre navigation pourra
être immédiatement modifier revenir au
212 revenir 212 or 212 seont la valeur
zéro la barre au 200 dos seulement au
premier coup de vent sérieux force10
dans le golfe de gascogne ce merveilleux
ordinateur est tombé en panne pendant
quelques heures il ne supportait pas la
route
rien de grave un défaut de jeunesse sans
doute et puis le guillaume a à sa
disposition une multitude d'autres
instruments mais ça montre tout de même
que plus le matériel devient sophistiqué
plus il devient fragile aussi et ce
n'est pas un hasard si les pertes de
bateaux ont beaucoup progressé
20 à 50% en plus au cours de ces deux
dernières années
même vraiment en sécurité sur un bateau
oui autant en sécurité que sur un autre
peut-être même plus pourtant c'est les
bateaux qui peuvent accoster presque
nulle part seulement dans les ports
spécialité
oui bien sûr charger un chargé parce
qu'évidemment bateau comme celui ci n'y
allais je peux aller quand même normal
de porc chargé il s'est limité sur la
route du golfe persique vous pouvez
aller où par exemple dans combien
d'endroits lisbonne à peu près tout
en fait avec ses îles flottantes qui ne
peuvent aborder nulle part c'est toute
une conception du transport pétrolier
qui pour revoir
est il raisonnable par exemple de
laisser entrer ces monstres dans la
manche la mer la plus fréquentée de vie
bien sûr le guillaume a par exemple à
deux moteurs qui réduisent les risques
de pagnes
il faut savoir que la puissance totale
de ses moteurs apparemment gigantesque
cette puissance est minime par rapport à
la taille du bateau si aucune
comparaison c'est comme si on man ray
elliot de 12 mètres avec un moteur d'un
cheval seulement et puis il y a les
autres dangers en transportant du
pétrole
on risque incendie ou une explosion là
les mesures prises sur ces pétroliers
géants semble réellement au point moyen
puissant de protection contre les
incendies par exemple mais aussi
élimination des gaz explosifs dans les
citernes
enfin surveillance permanente de ces
citernes fractionné en petites unités
grâce à ce deuxième ordinateur qui
calcule à chaque instant toutes les
tensions qui existent entre leur
paroisse reste que les quatre cinquièmes
de la pollution de la mer par les
hydrocarbures ne vient pas des accidents
mais du nettoyage des soutes en pleine
mer pourtant il existe des procédés
décantation chimique par exemple qui
permettent de nettoyer les types terne
sans polluer en principe huit pétroliers
sur dix sont équipés de ce système on
récupère donc une petite quantité de
produits gras qu'on stocke dans des
citernes réservé à cet effet qui servent
de citernes de décantation et on ne
rejette que l'eau décanter de ces
citernes
elle reste que tous les bateaux tous les
pétroliers font ça et respecte ses
règles devrait le faire tous les
pétroliers sont équipés d'une
installation peut-être pas de lavage
route certainement pas de lavage au
khroub mais tous sont des chicanes de
décantation et tous les pétroliers
devraient le faire mais ne font pas tous
le font mais
joue moins bien ou plus ou moins à fond
ainsi des officiers ne m'ont pas caché
que certains bateaux des français même
lorsqu'il était loin dans le sol indien
par exemple nettoyer sans précaution à
l'avenir les réglementations et aussi la
prise de conscience des hommes viendront
sans doute à bout de cette pollution
ce qu'on ne pourra jamais éliminer par
contre c'est l'accident
l'enchaînement imprévisible des hasards
comme pour les gros avions
les sinistres deviendront sûrement plus
rares mais le gigantisme des bateaux
prendront leurs conséquences beaucoup
plus dramatiques
ce matin si j'en crois la météo il n'y a
pas de raison de ne pas la croire
on a enregistré une température de moins
17 degrés à reims et à 13 heures il
faisait encore dans la capitale
champenoise la bagatelle de -7 degrés en
dessous de zéro
certains en revanche connaissaient ou
presque la douceur de l'été c'est ainsi
qu'à pau à 13 heures le thermomètre
était monté à 20 degrés demain il fera
encore froid de la manche orientale haut
rhin et au jura il fera froid avec de la
neige et de la pluie verglacée de la
normandie à la région parisienne de la
bourgogne et à la franche-comté il y
aura des nuages de la flandre à l'alsace
ailleurs dans du très nuageux souvent
pluvieux avec même de la neige au dessus
de 2000 mètres la neige les suisses
n'ont pas manqué depuis quelques jours
c'est ainsi que dans la région de
zermatt près de 50000 personnes sont
restées est coupé du reste du territoire
helvétique durant plusieurs heures entre
hier et ce matin
plusieurs avalanches avaient coupé les
routes une de ces avalanches s'étaient
même abattu sur la gare de zermatt et la
voie ferrée
il n'y a pas eu de victimes la
circulation ferroviaire ce soir abu être
rétablie normalement
voilà cette édition est maintenant
terminée en fin de programme aux
alentours de 23h45 c'est hervé claude
qui vous donnera les dernières
informations de cette journée quant à
moi je vous retrouve demain à 13 heures
bonne soirée à demain